turning to the economy new evidence that
prices you pay for most everyday items
are still rising at Red Hot pace of the
government report out yesterday shows
the overall inflation rate was 8.2
percent over the past year which is more
than Economist expected we are joined
Now by CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger how you doing very well
thank you all right so what's going on
with the stubbornly high prices well you
know it wasn't just the headline at 8.2
it's the core rate also because that
pulls out food and energy food was up a
lot last month and that has to do with a
lot of supply chain issues drought and
some avian flu issues around eggs
pulling that out 6.6 percent without
food and energy that's the price
increase from a year ago how does Pace
in 40 years and this is incredibly
important because that really means that
even if supply chain issues start to
ease up for goods services are
accelerating right now and that's cause
for concern there's also news about
social security yeah the only good news
about high inflation is that when we
talk about the cost of living adjustment
for Social Security recipients this is
70 million people they're getting an 8.7
percent increase in Social Security
benefits next year that means an average
monthly increase of an extra hundred
forty dollars for average social
security beneficiaries that's going to
help them fight inflation for next year
the stocks jumped a little bit around
2.5 percent why it was a crazy day this
report gets released and it looked like
stocks were going to open down by two
and a half percent we end up we end up
the day with a two and a half percent
increase and I'm going to tell you
nobody understands why this is a
guesstimate about what people think the
Federal Reserve is going to do you know
what they're going to do they're going
to raise interest rates again at the
next meeting it's in November we're
going to get another 0.75 percent
increase in short-term interest rates
that means the cost of borrowing will
continue to increase for Americans that
was the largest one day percent gain in
the stocks in almost two years
unbelievable thank you for joining us
appreciate you